what do i always try to do here you know
i always try to give hope and there is
always hope there really is and and we
just have to keep focusing on that we
have to push back and tell the truth
even when it is difficult to do so uh so
there was a big nra convention over the
last couple days uh and here is senator
ted cruz making sense many of these same
people make their accusations from
behind great bulwarks of safety
from gated communities equipped with
private security or at the very least
from safe and expensive neighborhoods
protected by high home prices
and low crime rates
such people can afford an indulgent
ideology
that ignores reality
as is so often the case
those furthest from the halls of power
are the most dependent on the ability to
defend themselves
in an age where elites embrace defunding
the police
when homelessness runs rampant
when gangs dominate entire communities
and when radical district attorneys
refused to prosecute violent crime in
cities across america
rarely
has the second amendment been more
necessary to secure the rights
of our fellow citizens
[Music]
[Applause]
everything he said there was true
everything he said there was true any of
these politicians do you think chuck
schumer has armed security around him of
course he does do you think mark
zuckerberg has armed security at his
house of course he does do you think
wherever their children go to school any
of these people literally any of these
people where their children go to school
where they live have better policing or
or their own private security or all of
those things yes that's what they have
for themselves
they want to take away your ability to
defend yourself this is not a radical
thing that i'm saying it is an obvious
thing understand it and know it and then
there's the broader conversation here
which is about what political priorities
are in dc they don't really do anything
right they seemingly always just want
more of us more from us whether it's our
money or it's our attention or it's our
rights
so donald trump also spoke at the nra
convention
and here he made a good point about what
we do with funding seemingly we can give
money to everybody else but we can't
take care of ourselves this is not a
matter of money this is a matter of will
if the united states has 40 billion
dollars to send to ukraine we should be
able to do whatever it takes to keep our
children
safe at home
at a radical position right basically
every senator except for i think 13
republicans voted just in the last two
weeks to give another 40 billion dollars
to ukraine we have no idea where that
money's going we're not getting receipts
on any of that if you want more on that
i did a short interview with senator
rand paul who did vote against it which
is up on youtube and rumble and
everywhere else
but we can find money to give weapons
bombs guns etc we can give that using
our own money that we don't have that
we're borrowing from china uh we can
send that over to ukraine but why can't
we how come nobody proposed all right
how about i don't know four billion
dollars to defend our schools how about
that how about that how about we really
look at what is the what are the
weaknesses of these schools i'm not even
saying this is fully the answer because
i really think this is far more of a
mental health issue but what about
really assessing what every
public school and private school and
charter school and everything should be
doing right now and i suspect the public
ones certainly the wealthy public
that i suspect that the private ones and
the charter ones especially the wealthy
ones are doing it right now really
assessing hey what are our security
guards doing what are our
points of entry what are the weak spots
here and all of those things but we're
not really going to do that
right i don't think randy weingarten is
going to be pushing for that right she's
head of the the teachers union i don't
think she's really going to be pushing
for that she'll be pushing for getting
rid of guns leaving the schools more
exposed